[Music]
[Music]
I began to really look around and as I
saw other young teenagers young women I
saw myself in them I saw people that
didn't believe in them and I saw them
having dreams that no one really
understood but I really really think
it's just that one on one the girl the
woman myself in that chair at that hour
that we get together like that's me
making a difference I had a high school
counselor and I was in the 11th grade I
was pretty much a straight-a student and
when I went to see her she said you can
go to Compton Beauty College because
you're you seem to be good at that or
you can go to Compton Community College
and start there and we'll see a teacher
that I also told the story to took me to
UC Irvine one day and I went on a
Saturday I recall I was admitted on the
spot I mean everything happened so fast
but there was a huge semi-truck and it
literally took off the left side of my
driver's seat people always think like
gosh poor girl you know like God it must
be so hard I started taking the
opportunity to mentor one of them wants
to study abroad and she was telling me
that she was looking for a fourth job
and I said why are you looking for a
fourth job she said well I almost have
enough money to pay the rent in Spain
for a year but if I take on a fourth job
in the next six weeks I'll have money
for the fifth so I said well I'll make a
deal with
[Music]
if you promise to mentor someone else
I'll pay for it and just to see thee
it wasn't relief but it was somebody
believes that I can do this
was worth all I didn't dry for about six
months so I put on some good running
kicks and ran the streets of LA running
was my gosh I'd like saved my life
[Music]
what would I define successes now oh man
nothing out there it's not out there
nothing out there is going to feel here
that I can always wake up and think I
did enough yesterday but I can do more
tomorrow if there's like a fox in the
forest I always see compared to that and
he loses a lay he doesn't say okay well
how am I gonna run with three he just
runs out there he just we just do it and
I think that's what people are like gosh
I don't I could never and like you could
we all could
[Music]